This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Your online activity creates tons and tons of data, and that data is valuable. Entire sectors of the economy are built on this principle. But there is one data set that has proven to be so incredibly valuable because it was available for free for anyone to use, and this data was gathered during the investigation of a crime. This is the story of the Enron emails that were collected as the government was building the case to prosecute the company that became the poster child for corporate crime. But since then, these emails have helped create new technologies,
这里是《99% Invisible》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。你的在线活动会产生海量数据，而这些数据价值连城。整个经济领域都是建立在这一原则之上的。但有一个数据集被证明极具价值，因为它免费供所有人使用，且这些数据是在犯罪调查期间收集的。这就是安然公司（Enron）电子邮件的故事，这些邮件是在政府为起诉这家成为企业犯罪代名词的公司而收集证据时被获取的。但从那时起，这些邮件帮助创造了新技术，
fight terrorism, and added to our understanding of how we communicate. It's an incredible story. And when I heard it on business insiders brought to you by podcast, formerly called Household Name, I was like, damn, I wish we reported that. And since they did such a sell our job, I thought we'd just present their story to you. It is fascinating, you're going to love it.
打击了恐怖主义，并加深了我们对沟通方式的理解。这是一个不可思议的故事。当我在《Business Insider》的播客（前身为《Household Name》）中听到这个故事时，我心想，该死，真希望是我们报道的。既然他们做得如此出色，我想我们还是直接把他们的故事呈现给你们。这非常引人入胜，你们一定会喜欢的。
To guide you through this twisted tale of crime and data, here's Dan Bobgoth. Imagine you're working for love it. To guide you through this twisted tale of crime and data, here's Dan Bobgoth. Imagine you're working for a big company, like say number seven on the Fortune 500 list. Oh, and it's around the year 2000. There's no Facebook, no Gmail. We're not thinking that much about privacy. And then the company you work for
为了带你领略这个关于犯罪与数据的曲折故事，有请丹·鲍布科夫。想象一下，你在一家大公司工作，比如《财富》500强排名第七的公司。哦，那大约是在2000年。没有Facebook，没有Gmail。我们当时并没有过多考虑隐私问题。然后，你工作的公司
goes bust in spectacular fashion. Well, it was the corporate fraud case that since shockwaves across Houston and the entire country the fall of Enron? Congressional hearings begin this morning in the Enron investigation. And then some regulator in Washington releases your work emails, all of them.
以一种惊人的方式倒闭了。好吧，这就是那起在休斯顿乃至全国引发轩然大波的企业欺诈案——安然的倒台。国会听证会今天上午在安然调查案中开始。然后，华盛顿的一位监管机构发布了你的工作邮件，所有的邮件。
So all of a sudden, a lot of things in your life just became public, like? July 28, 1999, 142 pm. Attached are the above reference documents. Hard copies will follow. But also, some perhaps less routine business dealings. Subject, re, dark star. To further insulate the coal group
所以突然之间，你生活中的很多事情都公开了，比如：1999年7月28日下午1点42分。随信附上上述参考文件。纸质副本随后寄出。但也包括一些可能不那么常规的商业交易。主题：关于“黑星”（Dark Star）。为了进一步保护煤炭部门
and you from any claim that Enron misused the information, I suggest that you transfer the information to me and I will hold it for safekeeping. And some cliche, bad workplace behavior. No subject. I'm heading to New Orleans this weekend to do some partying. No Europa, just sluts in the quarter. And let's not forget the classic 90s chain emails.
和你免受任何关于安然滥用信息的指控，我建议你将信息转交给我，我会妥善保管。还有一些陈词滥调、糟糕的职场行为。无主题。我这个周末要去新奥尔良参加派对。没有欧罗巴，只有区里的荡妇。别忘了经典的90年代连锁邮件。
Hope you're having a pleasant first week of 1999, thought it would forward this on. Top 22 signs that you've had too much of the 90s. 22 cleaning up the dining area means getting it. There were even some exchanges with co-workers that really shouldn't have been in your work in box. No subject. Let me know when you're leaving. I'll be leaving probably in about 30 to 45 minutes.
希望你1999年的第一周过得愉快，想转发这个给你。90年代过头的22个迹象。22：清理用餐区意味着把它收拾干净。甚至还有一些与同事的交流，真的不应该出现在你的工作收件箱里。无主题。告诉我你什么时候走。我大概30到45分钟后离开。
Walk me out. I'll give you a big wet kiss. But I want more. I'll give you all you want. The emails you just heard read by actors are real emails. There are just a few of the hundreds of thousands sent around the year 2000 by some of Enron's highest ranking employees. few of the hundreds of thousands sent around the year 2000 by some of Enron's highest ranking employees.
送我出去。我会给你一个湿吻。但我想要更多。我会给你所有你想要的。你们刚才听到的由演员朗读的邮件是真实的邮件。这只是2000年左右由安然公司一些最高级别员工发送的数十万封邮件中的几封。
And when these emails became public, for the first time, there was a database of thousands of real emails sent by real people that was available to the public and researchers, and at least one podcast host. But these emails aren't just a curiosity, they're not just a time capsule. I bet something you use today was touched by these emails aren't just a curiosity. They're not just a time capsule. I bet something you use today was touched by these emails. They've become a huge part of all of our lives. From business inside our institution, this is household name. Brands you can trust.
当这些邮件首次公开时，公众和研究人员，以及至少一位播客主持人，第一次获得了一个由真实的人发送的数千封真实邮件的数据库。但这些邮件不仅仅是好奇心，它们不仅仅是一个时间胶囊。我敢打赌，你今天使用的某些东西就受到这些邮件的影响。它们已经成为我们所有人生活的重要组成部分。来自《Business Insider》，这是《Household Name》。值得信赖的品牌。
Brands you know stories you don't. I'm Dan Bobcoff. Enron collapsed because of greed and corruption and fraud. But the emails Enron employees sent and received have had an astounding afterlife. They were used to create Siri and develop spam filtering and artificial intelligence. They've helped us understand gender and power. But at what cost? What happens when so much of our technology is based on the writings of some fallen energy tycoons?
你所知道的品牌，你所不知道的故事。我是丹·鲍布科夫。安然的倒闭是因为贪婪、腐败和欺诈。但安然员工发送和接收的邮件却有着惊人的“来世”。它们被用来创建Siri、开发垃圾邮件过滤和人工智能。它们帮助我们理解了性别与权力。但代价是什么？当我们的许多技术都基于一些倒台的能源大亨的文字时，会发生什么？
And should the emails have been released in the first place? This is the first time we've ever seen a video about how to use the internet. This is the first time we've ever seen a video about how to use the internet. These days, Enron is pretty much shorthand for corporate scandal. But back in the 90s, Enron was an energy trading company based in Houston. It bought, sold, and traded natural gas and electricity, and also apparently pulp and paper.
这些邮件当初应该被公开吗？这是我们第一次看到关于如何使用互联网的视频。这是我们第一次看到关于如何使用互联网的视频。如今，安然几乎成了企业丑闻的代名词。但在90年代，安然是一家总部位于休斯顿的能源贸易公司。它买卖和交易天然气和电力，显然还有纸浆和纸张。
But the thing Enron is really famous for is how it collapsed. In 2001, it was the biggest bankruptcy ever at that point. It looked suspicious, because the company was telling everyone it was profitable and successful. And then out of nowhere, it went bust. The SEC investigated, prosecutors pounced, a number of top executives went to prison for fraud. Guilty verdicts in the biggest case of corporate fraud in history. Lawyers for Jeffrey Skilling and Kathlay threw around complicated notions about margin calls and short selling.
但安然真正出名的是它的倒闭方式。2001年，这是当时有史以来最大的破产案。这看起来很可疑，因为该公司当时告诉所有人它盈利且成功。然后毫无征兆地，它就倒闭了。美国证券交易委员会（SEC）进行了调查，检察官迅速介入，多名高管因欺诈入狱。这是历史上最大企业欺诈案的有罪判决。杰弗里·斯基林和肯尼思·莱的律师们抛出了关于追加保证金和卖空的复杂概念。
But the reason we have access to thousands of Enron's emails is because of something else. Something Enron did in California. California became one of the first states to deregulate its energy markets in the mid-90s. The idea was to introduce market forces and competition, you know lower prices and such, Enron had lobbied hard for this, and then after deregulation came into play, mysteriously, California started experiencing serious energy shortages. And whenever that happened, Enron and some other companies just coincidentally raked in a whole bunch of cash.
但我们能接触到数千封安然邮件的原因是另一回事。安然在加州做了一些事情。加州在90年代中期成为首批放松能源市场管制的州之一。其想法是引入市场力量和竞争，你知道，降低价格之类的。安然曾为此大力游说，而在放松管制生效后，加州神秘地开始经历严重的能源短缺。每当这种情况发生时，安然和其他一些公司就会巧合地赚取大量现金。
The worst one was physical withholding, so you just say, I'm not going to run my powerplant tomorrow. Pat Wood was an energy regulator with FERC, the Federal Energy Regulatory Commission. It was his job to help investigate this. Now, no one was dumb enough to say I'm not going to run it so I can make money off of a scarcity price, but that's what happens. I mean, when you don't run your power plant, which they were obligated to do, would says power suppliers would overplay maintenance issues, exaggerate problems so they could shut down their plans.
最糟糕的是物理扣留，也就是你说：“我明天不运行我的发电厂了。”帕特·伍德是联邦能源监管委员会（FERC）的能源监管员。他的工作是协助调查此事。现在，没有人傻到说“我不运行它是为了从稀缺价格中获利”，但事实就是这样。我的意思是，当你不运行本应运行的发电厂时，伍德说电力供应商会夸大维护问题，夸大问题以便关闭他们的工厂。
What kind of smart engineers can actually go question that? I mean, you really had to get people under oath to really figure all this out. There were other tricks. And Ron would buy power in California, move it to Nevada, and then sell it back at a profit. And Ron was making bank, but by the second half of 2000, the tricks turned into a full-on energy crisis. Electricity prices in California shot up 800% at one point. There were rolling blackouts affecting more than a million people.
什么样的聪明工程师能真正去质疑这一点？我的意思是，你真的必须让人宣誓才能真正弄清楚这一切。还有其他伎俩。安然会在加州购买电力，将其转移到内华达州，然后再以利润卖回。安然赚得盆满钵满，但到了2000年下半年，这些伎俩演变成了一场全面的能源危机。加州的电价一度飙升了800%。轮流停电影响了超过一百万人。
Now Pat Wood is a free market sky. He was all for deregulating California's energy market. But what Enron did with that freedom is not what he had in mind when he was promoting free markets. I'm a big passionate defender of competition, but I'm ruthless against people who, you know, want to eff it up. So, for investigated Enron and the market manipulators, and through the investigation got tons of documents,
现在，帕特·伍德是一个自由市场主义者。他完全支持放松加州的能源市场管制。但安然利用这种自由所做的事情，并不是他在推动自由市场时所想的那样。我是一个充满激情的竞争捍卫者，但我对那些想要搞砸它的人毫不留情。因此，FERC调查了安然和市场操纵者，并通过调查获得了大量文件，
like these memos describing in detail how Enron planned to manipulate the California markets to make lots of money. And they were really pretty shocking. I mean, you know, for one who loves competition and markets, it just kind of made me nauseated because I thought, man, is this the enterprise that I help create?
比如这些详细描述安然如何计划操纵加州市场以赚取巨额利润的备忘录。它们确实相当令人震惊。我的意思是，你知道，对于一个热爱竞争和市场的人来说，这让我感到恶心，因为我想，天哪，这就是我帮助创造的企业吗？
Was this house of cards? I mean, this is ridiculous. So I walked down the hall and showed it to my other three commissioners, and I said, you know, I got a problem with this. During the investigation, Pat Wood and Ferck were mostly focused on the memos, but they'd also gotten a whole lot of emails from Endrun.
这是空中楼阁吗？我的意思是，这太荒谬了。所以我走到大厅，把它展示给我的其他三位委员，我说，你知道，我对这个有问题。在调查期间，帕特·伍德和FERC主要关注备忘录，但他们也从安然那里得到了大量邮件。
It was huge, it was thousands of, I don't remember if it's terabytes or whatever the word after teratism, but it was huge. So what were you finding in these emails that you wanted people to see? You know, 95% of them were about nothing that we were interested in. But it's hard to read. I mean, it was a huge amount of emails. So the other question was, you know, there might be something that somebody finds here
规模巨大，有数千个，我不记得是太字节还是太字节之后的词，但规模非常大。那么你在这些邮件中发现了什么你想让人们看到的东西？你知道，95%的内容与我们感兴趣的事情无关。但很难阅读。我的意思是，邮件数量太庞大了。所以另一个问题是，你知道，可能有人在审查这些东西时会发现我们可能遗漏的东西。
from reviewing this stuff that we might have missed. ["Must Have Been A Hard Decision"] Firk had to decide what to do with all this data. In 2003, Pat Wood was pissed about what Enron had done. So he kept thinking about transparency. Just put it all out there and let the public see what the company did.
FERC必须决定如何处理所有这些数据。2003年，帕特·伍德对安然所做的事情感到愤怒。所以他一直在思考透明度。把一切都公开，让公众看看这家公司做了什么。
But I'm sure behind the scenes, it must have been a hard decision to decide whether to release all these emails with all this personal information and irrelevant. Yeah, but I will tell you, honestly, then, that issue did not with not front and center as much as I, as much as it would be today, for example. So Pat Wood and the FERC commissioners made a fateful decision.
但我敢肯定，在幕后，决定是否发布所有这些包含个人信息和无关内容的邮件一定是一个艰难的决定。是的，但我可以诚实地告诉你，当时那个问题并没有像今天这样成为焦点。所以帕特·伍德和FERC委员们做出了一个决定性的决定。
They just dumped the entire email archive on the internet. All the end run emails about gas trading and meeting scheduling and also the divorces and affairs and talk of parties, it was all there. I've heard different versions of what happened next. Some people say the emails were cleaned up that someone went through and got rid of social security numbers and bank account info, and stuff like that.
他们直接把整个邮件存档扔到了互联网上。所有关于天然气交易、会议安排以及离婚、外遇和派对谈话的安然邮件，都在那里。我听过接下来发生的事情的不同版本。有些人说邮件被清理过，有人检查并删除了社会安全号码和银行账户信息之类的东西。
Other people say, and run employees were actually given a chance to go through and flag things they thought should be redacted. But either way, Pat would have met Firk didn't try that hard to clean the emails up. And then after they were public, he just kind of forgot about the emails, until I called a few weeks ago. And so what they were public, he just kind of forgot about the emails until I called a few weeks ago. And so what did you think would happen when you put all these emails
另一些人说，安然员工实际上有机会检查并标记他们认为应该编辑的内容。但无论如何，帕特·伍德和FERC并没有太努力地清理这些邮件。在它们公开后，他基本上就忘了这些邮件，直到我几周前打电话给他。那么当你把所有这些邮件放到世界上时，你以为会发生什么？
out in the world? Never dreamed. I mean, when you told me, when we talked last week, when you told me what had gone on, I mean, I can't tell you how much I've been looking at on the web since you pointed me in that direction. There was so much on the web about this information. And I had no idea what would come of this. The emails took on a life of their own, far beyond what anyone at Enron or FUR could have imagined. Artificial intelligence, voice assistance, counterterrorism software, all have roots in the Enron emails.
做梦也没想到。我的意思是，当你告诉我，当我们上周交谈时，当你告诉我发生了什么时，我的意思是，我无法告诉你自从你指引我那个方向后，我在网上看了多少东西。网上关于这些信息的内容太多了。我根本不知道这会带来什么。这些邮件有了自己的生命，远远超出了安然或FERC任何人的想象。人工智能、语音助手、反恐软件，都源于安然的邮件。
After FERC released the Enron emails back in 2003, they just kind of sat there. Even though they were public, no one was really reading them, because they were a mess. Like imagine you log into your email and you need to find one specific message, except there's no search function. You can't organize by date or sender or subject line, there's spam everywhere. That's what the Enron emails were like, and there were like half a million of them. But this is where the Enron email's strange afterlife begins. First, some academics bought the emails from FERC. It became known as the Enron Corpus.
在FERC于2003年发布安然邮件后，它们就那样放着。尽管它们是公开的，但没有人真正阅读它们，因为它们一团糟。就像想象一下你登录你的电子邮件，需要找到一条特定的信息，但没有搜索功能。你不能按日期、发件人或主题行组织，到处都是垃圾邮件。安然的邮件就是这样，大约有五十万封。但这就是安然邮件奇怪的“来世”开始的地方。首先，一些学者从FERC购买了这些邮件。它被称为“安然语料库”（Enron Corpus）。
Corpus, by the way, is my new favorite word. The Enron Corpus cost 10 grand. Then the researchers got to work cleaning it up, pairing it down, and organizing it into something that could be cataloged and searched and studied. And then, they went wild. They wrote papers, ran experiments, invented whole new areas of research,
顺便说一下，“语料库”是我最喜欢的新词。安然语料库花了1万美金。然后研究人员开始清理、精简并将其组织成可以编目、搜索和研究的东西。然后，他们疯狂了。他们撰写论文、进行实验、开创了全新的研究领域，
like network science. My name's PJ Lamberson, and I'm an assistant professor in the communication department at UCLA. My research focuses on social networks and collaboration. We called PJ Lamberson because he was actually our producer, Sarah Wyman's professor.
比如网络科学。我叫PJ·兰伯森，是加州大学洛杉矶分校传播系的助理教授。我的研究重点是社交网络和协作。我们联系了PJ·兰伯森，因为他实际上是我们制片人莎拉·怀曼的教授。
Yeah, and that is a first day of class I will never forget. What happened? It was just so cool. Like, we all came in and on the board, he had projected a network that was made up of the N-RON emails. And so what we're looking at is a bunch of dots basically arranged in a pattern.
是的，那是我永远不会忘记的第一堂课。发生了什么？太酷了。我们都进去了，他在黑板上投影了一个由安然邮件组成的网络。所以我们看到的是一堆基本排列成图案的点。
And every dot represents an email address in the corpus. And you can tell so much about Enron just from looking at this map, Dan. Like what? Some of the dots are bigger than other dots, which means that they're getting more emails. So are those the powerful people? Yeah. And you can also tell that like some people are getting way more emails than they're sending, which is also kind of indicative of them being more important maybe. But then the really cool thing, like the reason I still remember this class four years
每一个点代表语料库中的一个电子邮件地址。丹，仅从这张地图上你就能看出关于安然的很多信息。比如什么？有些点比其他点大，这意味着它们收到的邮件更多。所以那些是权力人物吗？是的。你还可以看出有些人收到的邮件比发送的多得多，这也可能表明他们更重要。但真正酷的事情，就是我四年后还记得这堂课的原因，
after the fact, is that if you take a step back and just look at the entire network, you see something that's really interesting. What's that? So the way the map is organized, you can see projects, because people at work will email back and forth when they're working on something. Like we did with this episode. Exactly.
是如果你退后一步，看看整个网络，你会看到一些非常有趣的东西。那是什么？地图的组织方式，你可以看到项目，因为人们在工作时会为了某件事来回发邮件。就像我们做这一集一样。完全正确。
But the thing is, at Enron, they were not making podcasts, and some people were actually doing some really sketchy illegal things. And on this map, you can actually visually see the difference. Like the projects that were totally above board and fine look completely different from the ones that were shady. I guess the way I would describe it, if you look at the network where people are talking about like an elicit or illegal project, it looks like a really tight ball with a few little spikes sticking out of it. And so what that's showing you is that like for those illegal projects, the communication
但问题是，在安然，他们不是在做播客，有些人实际上在做一些非常可疑的非法事情。在这张地图上，你可以直观地看到区别。比如那些完全公开且没问题的项目，看起来与那些阴暗的项目完全不同。我想我会这样描述，如果你看人们谈论非法或违禁项目的网络，它看起来像一个非常紧密的球，上面伸出几个小尖刺。所以这向你展示的是，对于那些非法项目，沟通
is really concentrated among a core of individuals and they're not sharing that information or dispersing information about that project with other parts of the organization. Okay, and this is the best part because a computer has identified this. It's like a magic trick. The computer just has all of the data that's in the corpus that like in and of itself doesn't really make any sense to anyone and it just looks like a huge mess. But then once you run an algorithm on that data, it's like shining a black light on all of the corruption that was happening at N-Rot. Like you can just see it laid out bear in front of you in this network. Yeah, so this is like clearly very useful to people for a lot of things.
非常集中在核心个人身上，他们没有与组织的其他部分分享或分散关于该项目的信息。好的，这是最好的部分，因为计算机已经识别出了这一点。这就像一个魔术。计算机只是拥有语料库中的所有数据，这些数据本身对任何人来说都没有意义，看起来就像一团糟。但一旦你对这些数据运行算法，就像用黑光灯照亮安然发生的所有腐败。就像你可以看到它赤裸裸地呈现在你面前的这个网络中。是的，所以这显然对人们在很多事情上非常有用。
Yeah, and there's so much cool stuff that's happening with this technology. Like, people are using it to predict how viruses spread through populations because the software can identify the people within a group who are most likely to spread something to the rest of the group fast. So like the guy who's just going around shaking lots of people's hands will like show up
是的，这项技术正在发生很多很酷的事情。比如，人们正在用它来预测病毒如何在人群中传播，因为软件可以识别群体中最有可能迅速将某种东西传播给群体其他成员的人。所以那个到处和很多人握手的人就会出现在这个算法中。
in this algorithm. Right, but maybe one of the most interesting applications of this technology is that it's actually being used to identify terrorist cells. So if you have phone records from a group of people, you can run these algorithms on those phone records and they can detect these abnormal patterns of communication and you can see where the terrorists cells are. Okay, so the technology we developed using emails from Enron is now being used to fight terror.
对，但也许这项技术最有趣的应用之一是它实际上被用于识别恐怖分子小组。所以如果你有来自一群人的电话记录，你可以在这些电话记录上运行这些算法，它们可以检测到这些异常的沟通模式，你可以看到恐怖分子小组在哪里。好的，所以我们使用安然邮件开发的技术现在被用于打击恐怖主义。
Yeah, it's being used for all kinds of stuff. The Enron emails have been a huge opportunity for researchers like Sarah's Professor. They are publicly available, there's no copyright, researchers can swap them between institutions because no one owns them, but they've also been this really big deal for any researcher technology that involves language. Because these emails, this corpus, is a rare example of unfiltered, uncensored, totally organic human communication. So the bankruptcy of Enron was really the wonderful stroke
是的，它被用于各种各样的事情。安然邮件为像莎拉的教授这样的研究人员提供了巨大的机会。它们是公开可用的，没有版权，研究人员可以在机构之间交换它们，因为没有人拥有它们，但它们对于任何涉及语言的研究技术来说也是一件大事。因为这些邮件，这个语料库，是未经过滤、未受审查、完全有机的真实人类交流的罕见例子。所以安然的破产确实是研究人员的幸运。
of luck for researchers interested in conversation. This is Owen Rambo. He works at an artificial intelligence company called Elemental Cognition, used to teach a Columbia. He's been a part of lots of different research projects involving the N-Run emails, and a lot of them involve using the corpus to train computers to understand human language. It's unique. There's nothing quite like it. And it's real. You know, these are real people who are conversing not in order to create data for linguists, but in order to achieve their goals, whatever it was, you know, some work related goal or just tell each other jokes or whatever.
这是欧文·兰博。他在一家名为Elemental Cognition的人工智能公司工作，曾在哥伦比亚大学任教。他参与了许多涉及安然邮件的研究项目，其中许多涉及使用语料库来训练计算机理解人类语言。它是独一无二的。没有类似的东西。而且它是真实的。你知道，这些人是真实的人，他们交谈不是为了给语言学家创造数据，而是为了实现他们的目标，无论是什么，你知道，一些与工作相关的目标，或者只是互相讲笑话之类的。
Before the N-Rine emails, researchers like Rambo mostly had to work with stilted conversations or texts from old newspapers. One typical example is that people are students are brought into a lab and play a game against each other and engage in conversation as part of the game playing. So they're real conversations, but they're very limited and they're not naturally occurring. But these N-RON emails were what people really say to one another, especially when they don't think anyone is reading over their shoulder. And they've taught Rambo and computers a lot about how humans communicate.
在安然邮件之前，像兰博这样的研究人员大多不得不处理生硬的对话或旧报纸上的文本。一个典型的例子是，人们或学生被带进实验室，互相玩游戏，并作为游戏的一部分进行对话。所以它们是真实的对话，但它们非常有限，而且不是自然发生的。但这些安然邮件是人们真正对彼此说的话，尤其是在他们认为没有人盯着他们看的时候。它们教会了兰博和计算机很多关于人类如何沟通的知识。
Like based on syntax and word choice, you can predict if an email sender is male or female, a boss or an underling, bosses write shorter emails, male bosses tend to write direct emails, like give me the report by Monday, female bosses tend to say things like, would you be able to finish the report by Monday? I can say something like it's hot in here,
比如基于句法和词汇选择，你可以预测邮件发送者是男性还是女性，是老板还是下属，老板写的邮件更短，男性老板倾向于写直接的邮件，比如“周一前把报告给我”，女性老板倾向于说“你能在周一前完成报告吗？”我可以这样说：“这里很热”，
and it can either be a speech act to inform you of this fact or it can be a speech act to request a view that you turn on the air conditioning. It is hot in here. I'm sorry. Yeah. It's actually okay. These are the kinds of problems that cause bugs in artificial intelligence. Machines aren't great at interpreting nuance or tone or intent. They need practice and the end run Corpus is like one giant perfect training ground for developing those skills. It's helped train spam filters. Hey, the Enron emails had a lot of spam. We can connect you to the world's rich and famous, capture the attention of millionaires.
这既可以是一个通知你这一事实的言语行为，也可以是一个请求你打开空调的言语行为。这里很热。抱歉。是的。其实没关系。这些就是导致人工智能出现错误的问题。机器不擅长解释细微差别、语气或意图。它们需要练习，而安然语料库就像一个巨大的完美训练场，用于发展这些技能。它帮助训练了垃圾邮件过滤器。嘿，安然邮件里有很多垃圾邮件。我们可以让你与世界上的富人和名人联系，吸引百万富翁的注意。
The emails played a role in the development of Siri. Google reportedly used them when it was developing smart compose and Gmail. If you've used Gmail in the last year or so, you'll know what I'm talking about. This is that thing where it predicts what it thinks you want to say next. Sometimes it's actually really helpful.
这些邮件在Siri的开发中发挥了作用。据报道，谷歌在开发智能撰写（Smart Compose）和Gmail时使用了它们。如果你在过去一年左右使用过Gmail，你就会知道我在说什么。这就是它预测你接下来想说什么的功能。有时它确实非常有帮助。
But early versions have this bad habit of suggesting the phrase, I love you a little too often. If you're a researcher, you could spend hours sifting, organizing, studying these emails, and come to think of them purely as data. And then you might come across one like this. November 26, 2001, 723 PM, no subject. So you were looking for a one night stand after all? Whoever wrote that email probably didn't want it to have a long legacy.
但早期版本有一个坏习惯，就是建议“我爱你”这个短语的频率太高了。如果你是一名研究人员，你可能会花几个小时筛选、组织、研究这些邮件，并开始把它们纯粹视为数据。然后你可能会遇到这样一封：2001年11月26日，晚上7点23分，无主题。所以你终究是在寻找一夜情？写那封邮件的人可能不希望它有长久的遗产。
Did you feel any ethical qualms using the N-Rion emails? I relied on the process having worked. The process being that people were given the chance to withdraw emails. This said, I had my doubts, because in one of the releases, the very first email you saw was a very personal email, which probably the sender didn't or the receiver more likely didn't want to spread around. A few years ago, Owen Rambo was on a train in Texas. didn't or the receiver more likely didn't want to spread around. A few years ago, Owen Rambo was on a train in Texas. He and his husband were sitting in
你在使用安然邮件时感到任何道德不安吗？我依赖于这个过程已经奏效。这个过程是人们有机会撤回邮件。话虽如此，我有疑问，因为在其中一次发布中，你看到的第一封邮件是一封非常私人的邮件，发送者可能不希望，或者接收者更可能不希望它传播开来。几年前，欧文·兰博在德克萨斯州的一列火车上。
the dining car. And we started talking to the people who were added to our table and therefore were from Houston and I was working on Enron Day in and day out so I just said, oh did you work for Enron just like that. And the guy said yes. It was kind of like meeting a celebrity. This guy was one of the 150 in the corpus. And that was just sort of such a fascinating, weird coincidence. And it reminded me that this corpus,
他和他的丈夫坐在餐车里。我们开始和坐在我们桌子旁的人交谈，他们来自休斯顿，我当时每天都在研究安然，所以我只是说，“哦，你在安然工作吗？”就像那样。那个人说是的。这就像见到名人一样。这家伙是语料库中的150人之一。这真是一个迷人、奇怪的巧合。它提醒我，这个语料库，
which we give to our computers and run through algorithms and reduced to numbers and correlations, there really are real people at the other end. And you can meet them in Amtrak trains in Texas. And we then gossiped a little bit about other people who were mentioned in Run Corpus, who sort of almost seemed like people I know. So much of what we know about the world and how it works was somehow learned through this
我们把它交给计算机，通过算法运行，并简化为数字和相关性，在另一端确实有真实的人。你可以在德克萨斯的美国国铁列车上遇到他们。然后我们八卦了一下安然语料库中提到的其他人，他们看起来几乎像我认识的人。我们对世界及其运作方式的了解，很大程度上是通过这个
corpus. So much of our technology was developed using the corpus. But Owen Rambo is right. These aren't just data points. These aren't just emails. They're real people. At one energy company, at one period of time, right before it went bust. And that raises all sorts of red flags. More about that after this.
语料库学到的。我们的许多技术都是使用这个语料库开发的。但欧文·兰博是对的。这些不仅仅是数据点。这些不仅仅是电子邮件。他们是真实的人。在一家能源公司，在一段时间内，就在它倒闭之前。这引发了各种各样的危险信号。广告后会有更多内容。
There are two really obvious ethical issues with using the N-RON emails for anything. First of all, the people who wrote them did not sign up to be part of an academic study. They did not give researchers or robots permission to comb through all of their old conversations, and we'll get to that. But first, there's another problem here. The biases of the people writing the emails could become the biases of the AI system that's trained on them.
使用安然邮件做任何事情有两个非常明显的道德问题。首先，写这些邮件的人并没有报名参加学术研究。他们没有给研究人员或机器人许可去梳理他们所有的旧对话，我们稍后会谈到这一点。但首先，这里还有另一个问题。写邮件的人的偏见可能会成为在这些邮件上训练的人工智能系统的偏见。
Amanda Levin-Dowsky teaches at NYU and studies how bias creeps into technology. And she's worried that a ton of our artificial intelligence is based at least in part on the emails written by 150 people at an energy company that went bust because of fraud. First of all, they're not geographically representative. A lot of those emails were from people
阿曼达·莱文-道斯基在纽约大学任教，研究偏见如何潜入技术。她担心我们大量的人工智能至少部分基于150人在一家因欺诈而倒闭的能源公司写的邮件。首先，它们在地理上不具有代表性。很多邮件来自
based in the Houston office. It's not going to be representative in terms of corporate culture because it was a Houston-based oil and gas company. Because it's 150 senior executives at this company, you're not going to have the kind of gender or racial diversity that you might expect at a different sort of company. And if you're looking for evidence of this bias, you don't have to look any further than the emails themselves.
总部位于休斯顿办公室的人。就企业文化而言，它不具有代表性，因为它是一家总部位于休斯顿的石油和天然气公司。因为这是该公司150名高级管理人员，你不会有你在其他类型的公司可能期望的那种性别或种族多样性。如果你在寻找这种偏见的证据，你不需要看比邮件本身更远的地方。
Like there's this one email chain where someone sends an article about Bill Clinton's dog buddy getting hit by a car. The Enron official writes back, That is a shame for the dog. I'm very happy about Clinton's grief. There are emails about taking on the world wildlife fund. Subject, WWF Remember, this is the group that publicly announced that Enron has gotten away with murder for
比如有一个邮件链，有人发送了一篇关于比尔·克林顿的狗巴迪被车撞的文章。安然官员回信说：“这对那只狗来说是个遗憾。我对克林顿的悲伤感到非常高兴。”还有关于对抗世界自然基金会的邮件。主题：WWF。记住，这是那个公开宣布安然已经逍遥法外谋杀罪的组织，
years and we are going to get them. These are the emails underpinning a lot of our artificial intelligence. If there are misogynistic jokes, or shows of power in particular emails, those same implicit biases can become encoded in the AI that's trained on that corpus. Computer scientists tend to put this another way.
多年来，我们要抓住他们。这些是支撑我们许多人工智能的邮件。如果特定的邮件中有厌女症笑话或权力展示，同样的隐含偏见可能会被编码进在那个语料库上训练的人工智能中。计算机科学家倾向于用另一种方式表达这一点。
They call it garbage and garbage out. So, who wrote this stuff? I wanted to talk to someone who worked at NRAWN at the time, who actually wrote some of these emails. All the names are there, and I found that a lot of them list NRAWN as a former employer on their LinkedIn profiles.
他们称之为“垃圾进，垃圾出”。那么，是谁写了这些东西？我想和当时在安然工作、实际上写过其中一些邮件的人谈谈。所有的名字都在那里，我发现他们中的许多人在LinkedIn个人资料上将安然列为前雇主。
So I started calling. And I hit a lot of dead ends. We're sorry you have reached a number that has been disconnected or is no longer in service. If you have reached it. While I was searching though, I met someone else who was obsessed with the emails, a guy named Sam Levine. He's an artist and educator who has used the N-Run emails in his own work. And his art deals with these questions.
所以我开始打电话。我遇到了很多死胡同。“很抱歉，您拨打的号码已断开或不再服务。”在搜索时，我遇到了另一个痴迷于这些邮件的人，一个叫萨姆·莱文的家伙。他是一位艺术家和教育家，曾在自己的作品中使用过安然邮件。他的艺术处理了这些问题。
It forces people, like me, to really think about why reading through the corpus makes us feel so uncomfortable. So one of my favorite series of emails to read from the archivists between two people who were married and they both worked at Enron and they're going through a divorce because she cheated on him, I think. And you can read their whole correspondence. And what do you see in these emails? You know, it's like, I saw you today from a distance and I thought about what we used to have
它迫使像我这样的人真正思考为什么阅读语料库会让我们感到如此不舒服。我最喜欢阅读的存档邮件系列之一是两个已婚的人之间的，他们都在安然工作，他们正在经历离婚，因为她对他不忠，我想。你可以阅读他们的全部通信。你在这些邮件中看到了什么？你知道，就像，“我今天从远处看到了你，我想到了我们曾经拥有的，
and I'm so sorry and I hope we can be friends again one day and stuff like that, right? Do you feel like you're watching a relationship just to integrate? Yeah, it's also something you shouldn't read really. You know, it's invasive. and stuff like that. Do you feel like you're watching a relationship disintegrate? Yeah. It's also something you shouldn't read, really. It's invasive. Yeah, I mean, there's something like I feel kind of dirty,
我很抱歉，我希望有一天我们能再次成为朋友”之类的，对吧？你觉得你在看着一段关系瓦解吗？是的，这也是你不应该读的东西。你知道，这是侵入性的。是的，我的意思是，有些东西让我觉得有点脏，
reading these emails, even though it's so long ago, it's been public for so long. And yet, it feels like, am I just a voyeur here? It is very voyeuristic. I tried to reach that couple Sam Levine was talking about to ask them how they felt, but I got a voicemail Hi, Dan Bopcoff calling from business insider in New York Eventually I reached the guy by email. He said he's not angry about his emails being released, but he didn't want to do an interview
阅读这些邮件，尽管那是很久以前的事了，它公开了这么久。然而，感觉就像，我只是一个偷窥者吗？这非常具有窥淫癖。我试图联系萨姆·莱文提到的那对夫妇，问问他们的感受，但我得到了语音信箱。“你好，我是来自纽约《Business Insider》的丹·鲍布科夫。”最终我通过电子邮件联系到了那个人。他说他不生气他的邮件被发布，但他不想接受采访。
Sam Levine the artist has been living with these emails for a few years now. Along with his colleague, Tiga Brain, he used the emails as the basis of an experimental art project. So, our project is called The Good Life, and in The Good Life you get the opportunity to receive all of the emails from the Enron Archive, direct-try inbox in the order that they were originally sent, and with the appropriate amount of time between a Gmail. Apparently, a few hundred people have signed up to get their actual inboxes clogged with old Enron emails.
艺术家萨姆·莱文几年来一直与这些邮件生活在一起。他和他的同事蒂加·布雷恩一起，将这些邮件作为实验艺术项目的基础。所以，我们的项目叫《美好生活》（The Good Life），在《美好生活》中，你有机会收到安然存档中的所有邮件，直接进入你的收件箱，按照它们最初发送的顺序，并带有邮件之间适当的时间间隔。显然，几百人已经注册，让他们的实际收件箱被旧的安然邮件塞满。
Levin even did it himself. Do you have this on your main email account? Yeah. Is that, it's like not filtered or anything? No, no. So I read every single one. Oh my god. How much time do you spend a day on this? Not that long. And because like a lot of them are really short, you know. So it doesn't take that long to read all of them. And
莱文甚至自己也做了。你有这个在你的主要电子邮件账户上吗？是的。那是，它没有过滤或什么吗？不，不。所以我读了每一封。天哪。你每天花多少时间在这个上面？没那么久。因为像很多邮件都很短，你知道。所以读完所有邮件不需要那么久。而且
it's a really interesting experience, I think. Because it's sort of like a lot of times you'll see the email come in and it'll be like meeting in room 10 and 15 minutes and you're like, oh, oh no, I've missed a meeting. I didn't know about that meeting. And then you'll open up the email and you're like, oh, right, right. This happened in 1999 actually. It's okay. I didn't actually have to go to that meeting.
我认为这是一个非常有趣的经历。因为就像很多时候你会看到邮件进来，它会说“10点15分在房间开会”，你会想，“哦，哦不，我错过了一个会议。我不知道那个会议。”然后你会打开邮件，你会想，“哦，对了，对了。这实际上发生在1999年。”没关系。我其实不必去参加那个会议。
Ironically or perhaps fittingly, some of the Enron emails get caught in the Vien Spam filters. How do you feel about your emails getting caught in spam filters that might have been trained on the very emails that you were trying to send? I think it's really nice. It works, I guess. I think it's great. I still wanted to know how it felt to be someone
讽刺的是，或者也许恰如其分的是，一些安然邮件被困在垃圾邮件过滤器中。你对你的邮件被困在可能是在你试图发送的邮件上训练的垃圾邮件过滤器中有什么感觉？我觉得这真的很好。我想它奏效了。我觉得这很棒。我仍然想知道作为一个人是什么感觉
whose emails were released in the corpus. Who's every word at Enron is now parsed and dissected by researchers without their consent. Eventually, someone picked up. Hello. Hi. Is this Mitchell Taylor? Yes.
其邮件在语料库中被发布。他们在安然的每一个字现在都被研究人员在未经他们同意的情况下解析和剖析。最终，有人接听了。喂。你好。这是米切尔·泰勒吗？是的。
Hi, Dan Bobcoff from Business Insider in New York. How are you? Good, how are you? Good, thank you. So I'm calling you for an interesting reason. Mitch Taylor was a managing director at Enron. He's also the guy Owen Rambo ran into on a train a few years back. Owen Rambo?
你好，我是来自纽约《Business Insider》的丹·鲍布科夫。你好吗？很好，你呢？很好，谢谢。所以我打电话给你有一个有趣的原因。米奇·泰勒曾是安然的董事总经理。他也是欧文·兰博几年前在火车上遇到的那个人。欧文·兰博？
I had to jog his memory. Oh, oh, oh, oh, what's his last name? Rambo, R-A-M-B-O-W. I do remember this now. Okay, so I had him on the phone. This was my big shot. I wanted to know how he felt when all these emails were dumped on the web back in 2003. Yeah, you look at thoughts, some privacy advocates would have come to our defense, but at that
我不得不帮他回忆。哦，哦，哦，哦，他姓什么？兰博，R-A-M-B-O-W。我现在确实记得了。好的，所以我打通了他的电话。这是我的大好机会。我想知道当所有这些邮件在2003年被倾倒在网上时，他是什么感觉。是的，你看，一些隐私倡导者本可以为我们辩护，但在那个
point, being with Enron, there was no one coming near defense. No one gave a sh** at that point. We were the evil empire, so everyone was happy for any bad things that happened to Enron people. He told me that there was so much news about Enron, so bad press about Enron back then that the email dump didn't really register It was just another thing that happened. I've read some of Mitch Taylor's emails by the way most of them sound like work emails subject Re-project granted update
时候，在安然，没有人会来为我们辩护。那时候没人会在乎。我们是邪恶帝国，所以每个人都对安然员工发生的任何坏事感到高兴。他告诉我，当时关于安然的新闻太多了，关于安然的负面报道太多了，以至于邮件倾倒并没有真正引起注意。这只是发生的另一件事。顺便说一下，我读过米奇·泰勒的一些邮件，大多数听起来像工作邮件。主题：关于“重新授权项目”更新。
Thanks for the update with regard to further interference from the PN, and the comment that the PUCN must approve each generation. You get the idea. I don't think I've ever gone and looked at which ones they had. I certainly didn't have a mistress. I didn't have any criminal stuff going on now. Whether I've passed along an inappropriate joke, I may have it, and I tend to be rather sarcastic at times in emails. That aspect of it never come back to to bite me in any way at least
感谢关于进一步干扰PN的更新，以及关于PUCN必须批准每一代发电的评论。你明白意思了。我不认为我曾经去查看过他们有哪些。我当然没有情妇。我没有任何犯罪行为。至于我是否传递过不恰当的笑话，我可能有过，而且我倾向于在邮件中相当讽刺。那方面从来没有以任何方式回来咬我，至少
that I've seen or that I'm aware of. When I first heard about this story I remember thinking how weird and cool it is that the emails from N-RON of all companies have been so important in our lives, that the company died, but the emails live on. But the more I dug into it, the weirder I started to feel about the corpus. I really shouldn't be able to read about strangers, divorces, and affairs.
我见过或我知道的。当我第一次听到这个故事时，我记得我在想，安然公司的邮件在我们的生活中如此重要，公司死了，但邮件却活了下来，这既奇怪又酷。但我挖掘得越深，我对语料库的感觉就越奇怪。我真的不应该能够读到陌生人的离婚和外遇。
I shouldn't have access to someone's daycare scheduling, even if it happened two decades ago. But on the other hand, I use Siri. I like when Gmail suggests what I was going to say so I don't have to type it out. I think it's nice that some real good and some real human progress came out of the Enron collapse, but at what cost? I really wanted to know what Pat would think about all this now. After all, he's the guy who released them in the first place back when he was a regulator, and he told me he's lost sleep over it well it was hard because i said that there go you know it was just uh... you know the impact on all it would
我不应该有权访问某人的托儿所时间表，即使它是发生在二十年前。但另一方面，我使用Siri。我喜欢Gmail建议我想说的话，这样我就不必打字了。我认为安然的倒闭带来了一些真正的美好和真正的人类进步是件好事，但代价是什么？我真的很想知道帕特·伍德现在对这一切有什么看法。毕竟，他是在担任监管机构时发布这些邮件的人，他告诉我他为此失眠了。好吧，这很难，因为我说过，你知道，这只是……你知道，对所有这一切的影响……
and now that i've been through privacy breaches on my own and i just thought man i was a huge accomplice and doing that to lot of people might love him within the town right now live uh... there's probably about a of people whose privacy was impacted significantly by what I did who live in my area code. He said that if he could do it over again, he'd probably release a lot of the emails, but would have taken much more care to scrub out the personal stuff, to protect the people in there who were just collateral damage.
现在我自己也经历过隐私泄露，我当时想，天哪，我真是个巨大的帮凶，对很多人做了那种事，他们现在可能就住在镇上。在我所在的区号里，可能有不少人的隐私因为我的所作所为受到了严重影响。他说如果能重来一次，他可能会发布很多邮件，但会更小心地删掉个人信息，以保护那些仅仅是附带受害者的人。
What would you say to them? I'm sorry. If you didn't do anything wrong, you probably don't have anything to be ashamed of. If you did something wrong, I got you. For all those people in the middle who just had a normal expectation and privacy of just their personal affairs, or not personally, they their business affairs and how they would be viewed. You know, I think that's, you know, I wouldn't want that. What, you know, doing to others as you'd have them doing to you, I wouldn't probably want that done to me like that. This episode was produced by a bunch of people who had email addresses in the early 2000s,
你会对他们说什么？我很抱歉。如果你没做错什么，你可能没什么好羞愧的。如果你做了错事，那我就抓到你了。对于那些中间地带的人，他们只是对个人事务，或者说不是个人事务，而是他们的商业事务以及这些事务如何被看待有着正常的隐私期待。你知道，我认为，我不会想要那样。你知道，己所不欲，勿施于人，我可能不想被那样对待。这一集是由一群在21世纪初拥有电子邮件地址的人制作的，
like MusicMunchkin07 at Yahoo.com, Padulaa at Comcast.net and love to swim at Verizon.net. That's Sarah Wyman, Amy Padula, Jennifer Seagull, and there's also me. I think I was critical eye at AOL.com for a bit there. That was Dan Bobcoff. The show is called Brought to you by. It is excellent. It is produced by business insider.
比如Yahoo.com的MusicMunchkin07，Comcast.net的Padulaa，还有Verizon.net的love to swim。那是Sarah Wyman、Amy Padula、Jennifer Seagull，还有我。我想我有一段时间在AOL.com的用户名是critical eye。那是Dan Bobcoff。这个节目叫Brought to you by。非常棒。由商业内幕网制作。
We'll have a link in the show notes and on our website, 99pi.org. Joe Rosenberg organized this feature for us. We'll be back with an original homegrown 99pi story next week. See you then. Radio Topia. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们会在节目说明和我们的网站99pi.org上提供链接。Joe Rosenberg为我们策划了这个专题。下周我们将带回一个原创的、本土的99pi故事。到时候见。Radio Topia。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。